ha llegado el día del partido entre
Francia y Marruecos mientras algunos
seguían en el ya se echan uno pequeño
cotejo pues ya los ánimos también están
calentándose cada vez más la hinchada
que está muy contenta con muchas
expectativas ante este partido
Especialmente los marroquíes que son los
que más hemos visto aquí los marroquíes
que de hecho cientos de ellos no
pudieron viajar de Casa Blanca a doja un
cambio en la reglamentación por parte de
las autoridades
qataríes y justamente de los 30 vuelos
que debían partir solamente han llegado
siete incluso algunos viajeros que
fueron
detenidos o en todo caso no pudieron
entrar al país una vez ya habían llegado
a doja pero como sea es cierto que
estará esta mareada Roja en este estadio
albeico en estos silbidos lo cual será
ensordecedor difícil también para el
equipo de Francia de poder escucharse
por ahora hay dudas en cuanto a Francia
para saber el estado de dayu tupamecano
y de Adrián que han estado agripados y
por parte de los marroquíes dudas
especialmente en defensa y sobre todo
el día de ayer con el resto del equipo